here to co-pilot today is comedian actor
and friend of the show and my friend the
hilarious
cristela alonso
hi drew christella you are so
wearing the signature color look
i knew i was going to be part of it and
i just wanted to blend in
but also stand out if that makes any
sense i mean
you always do you're like the perfect
cozy fit
and yet someone to watch and stare at
and marvel at
oh i like that i'm adding that on my
tinder profile
by the way do it by the way all i want
to do is sarah know de bergerac
everyone's like dating profile anyone
who wants me to
i i'm i'm much better at stuff for other
people than myself
yeah exactly we we know what to do when
it comes to other people when ourselves
it's a little harder all right let's get
right into the news are you ready
yes okay npr reports that video game
minecraft teamed up with the
non-partisan non-profit rock the vote to
create build the vote
inside the video games kids can vote on
10 big issues like
gun control immigration now my goodness
video games can teach kids to vote you
know what i learned from video games for
stella
nothing it was the 80s there were no
goals are you a gamer
i'm a big gamer yeah actually right now
i'm completely obsessed with animal
crossing
which um i actually converted into like
a whole little thing where people can go
and visit my island and learn about
different issues as well
about the election like i was told but i
grew up with the atari
so it's weird how people don't
understand
kids now don't understand the luxury
they have of having characters that look
like people
i mean back in the atari days we had one
pixel and we're like that's you and it's
like yeah you
look like me no you're just talking
about that made me think of frogger
which the only thing that that ever did
for my life is every time i'm crossing a
street i think about it
all right cristela you have a story for
us
yes i do so you know
i have to tell you this is a pretty cool
story i don't understand how this is
possible
but this month astronaut katie rubin's
cast her absentee ballot from 120 miles
above earth she said it works the same
way as a military absentee voting
which makes sense because technically
she is overseas i
get it she really is she's over
all of it and she got it done and so we
can all too
okay um wait have you ever um
voted absentee ballot cristela
you know i actually had to do mail-in
this year and it was terrifying because
i'm always showing up in person
so it was it was just like i i held it
like a baby
yeah i wanted to make sure that like
everything was perfect but yes i have
and now i
i kind of like it you know it's like
there's no wrong way to do it over the
years i've done
in person absentee ballot paper
electronic i've done it all it's so
wonderful and your polling place might
be in a school or a library but if you
live in pittsburgh
it might just be in this guy's garage
every year
less corporate parks on the street and
offers his garage
as a neighborhood polling place i love
this a good late neighbor will let you
borrow a cup of sugar and a great one
will help you participate
in democracy oh that is so
cool what a cool idea i know i love him
by the way you found a really cute
voting story take it away
i totally do i did i did so in an effort
to get more people to the polls
there's this young organizer that's
trying the goat out the vote method
okay so mikka mc mccutchen
is holding virtual voter rallies from
the middle of this
iowa goat farm like literally she just
you know
she shows you all the goats while she's
giving you information and the goats are
so adorable
people from would come for the cuteness
but they stay for the information which
i think is totally adorbs
so you know uh vote with a goat if it
floats your boat
what i did that i just did it
you know what goat yoga goat voting
oh my god maybe at the same time even
you